hello believe nation I'm really excited
because I'm at 47 thousand subscribers
and I want to get to a hundred and I
feel like we have so much momentum going
now that all i need to do is keep
refreshing my page and i will get to a
hundred thousand subscribers hmm that
doesn't seem to be working like I
thought it would I know I'm going to
make a bunch of videos with cute kids
having fun and animals running around
that will help me get to 100,000
subscribers I got it I got the answer
you ain't got the answers man you are
you get the answers on it you ain't got
the ashes you ain't got the answers wait
time I've been doing this morning you
doing we got you come on you ain't got
the answers you ain't got the answers
I'm actually you ain't been doing
education bro you ain't be doing an
education come you don't have the
answers though okay I hear you but what
am I supposed to do Kanye the time is
now the time is now to express and for
people to believe in themselves the time
is now for it to be okay to be great
people in this world shun people for
being great for being a bright color for
standing out but the time is now to be
okay to be the greatest you got it I'm
gonna do what I do best model success so
I'm going to ask some of my successful
friends what advices they have when how
I can get to a hundred thousand jennifer
i need help i need to get to a hundred
thousand subscribers do you have any
advice for me don't remember as a dancer
and that's and I always told her she
goes what do you deserve as I'm in my
heart I'm a dancer got it in my heart
I'm a dancer too
you
so you want to be awake you want me to
get what you imagine imagine ish is good
for you you imagine something and you
calmly go out and get it you know the
meditation gives you that you know it's
almost like magic you know when you are
awake things become easier
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward that's how weird it
is done now if you know what you're
worth that guaty get what you're worth
but you got to be willing to take the
hits and not pointing fingers saying you
ain't where you want to be because of
him or her or anybody cowards do that in
that ain't you you're better than that
you
people get confused companies get
confused when they start getting bigger
they want to replicate their initial
success and a lot of them think well
somehow there's some magic in the
process of how that success was created
so they start to try to institutionalize
process across the company and before
very long people get very confused that
the process is the content that's
ultimately the downfall of IBM IBM has
the best process people in the world
they just forgot about the content you
want content steve i'll show you content
I drink I drinks classic coke at the
office and I bring cherry coke at home
is an incredible combination
don't lose no sleep over these haters
man the reason they got a problem with
your life is because they don't have a
life
you
in rap music you have to defend yourself
you know rap music is really aggressive
there's no place for a lack of
confidence in rap music you get chewed
up and spit out if you're not confident
and if you're not strong and assertive
um check e c8 k and city hit the corner
selling product anal drug dealer little
market in rich value much realer y'all
keep on baking check cash flow check
kill my 95 ain't goin back here huh snow
white side to my block TZ's looking guys
can hit away for ants easy microphone
check microphone check John believe team
and join me at the top
do my cardiovascular training in the
morning and then in the evening it did
the weight training yeah and they do
that every day
you
I started out taking a classical piano
lessons first yeah when I was at three
or four
you
I would Jungmann hands out now done some
110 I shouldn't show your joe hua Qian
Qing she yammin hua Qian Qing now I
forgot it GG yeah yeah yeah yeah mine
well Chan Chi Chi yeah Jan my kind of
war la Pole Nina xu zhi hao de yeah all
right hot those shoes way that yeah
i can speak chinese then like that yeah
thank you guys so much for all your love
and your support this has been one of
the most fun and most time-intensive
videos that I've ever made on the
channel it's been an amazing journey so
far getting a hundred thousand and I'm
looking forward to getting to that 1
million mark thank you guys again
continue to believe leave a comment let
me know what you think and I'll see you
soon
you
I
Oh
whoa nope oh yeah oh yeah are you
who
ice how are you today oh I have well I
time yeah what's that okay that's enough
we're good nice was it last one that huh
it's boring keep doing this we didn't
finish the song be kidding me but this
is okay we're done when there's the
whole thing no no no convo me she have
it recorded okay fine almost done